TV's longest-running primetime drama Law
& Order SVU is used to taking stories
ripped from the headlines so it's no
surprise that they would address George
Floyd's death and the black lives matter
protests head-on this one was just too
brutal this is what they call a tipping
point this is a point where people go
another this is a battle of humanity and
human rights it's not black and white
people fight back and ready to see it
SVU you know episode of this that's what
the writers are gonna do and I think if
they're touched by this it's gonna show
up in their writing the boys saw his
father get shot no child should ever see
that you'll see police brutality
protests and the cops on the show
struggling to understand why it's hard
to do the right thing producers have
also brought in new writers who will be
fresh voices for season 22 of the drama
we have to address it what kind of
conversations are you and Koko having
with Chanel right now like about the
state of the world and and everything
that that's happening she's only four
all you gotta teach to kids is human
rights everyone should be equal and no
matter what uniform you're wearing
there's good people and is bad people
you don't that's a message ice has been
working hard for a long time to get
across he stars in and is executive
producer of the new movie equal standard
the gritty drama about the shooting of
an off-duty black cop is dreaming now
and co-stars longtime friend Naughty by
nature's Trench try to go be a good cop
how many of us left looked at it as not
just a movie and look it's like a lesson
always say I hope one day to dig up
later than the Academy isn't raining for
the police officer so is that what you
hope we get out of this film like it
just sparks conversation and an
accountability there's people that have
never done dealt with the cops brutality
you've seen it
or it doesn't happen in their community
what I hope is are the protesters take
this with them in their day to day life
and when they see racism or they see
something wrong that they step up
against it as one person it's that hope
that drives ice forward along with this
little face that crashed our interview
they excuse my hair and now you look
beautiful her hood name is Sheneneh
she's wrapped royalty yeah
[Music]